are humans designed to be monogamous I
feel like anyone who's trying to disrupt
relationships I really admire that I
think that we have this one size fits
all toaster model of relationships where
if you think about a toaster you buy it
at the store you plug it in you never
expect it will get better why can't we
think about relationships more like an
iPhone where there's software and you
can constantly be getting more apps and
you can be deleting apps how can you
adapt and grow as the relationship
adopts and grows and so I would say I
have lots of friends that are in ethical
non-monogamy relationships who have
found that this is something that they
love to think about and talk about and
so I personally believe that there is a
lot of space to explore different
relationship structures